la embajadora de Estados Unidos ante
Naciones Unidas Nicky hayley inició su
campaña para la nominación presidencial
republicana de 2024 con lo que se
convierte en la primera contentora
oficial de Donald Trump en el camino de
los republicanos a la casa blanca de 51
años boicoteó la imagen del Magnate
durante su primer meeting que fue ayer
en Charleston Carolina del Sur allí
invitó a los seguidores a dejar atrás lo
que llamó las ideas obsoletas y además
lanzó una polémica propuesta escuchemos
tendremos límites de mandato para el
congreso y una prueba de competencia
mental obligatoria para los políticos
mayores de 75 años
esto una Clara alusión tanto al
expresidente Donald Trump como al actual
mandatario Joe biden y en contraposición
ella dice pertenecer a una nueva
generación de Liderazgo pero a 20 meses
de los comicios otras caras podrían
unirse a la pelea por la candidatura
vamos al análisis con Heidi James Smith
profesora e investigadora del
departamento de economía de la
universidad iberoamericana quien nos
acompaña desde Ciudad de México Heidi
Gracias por estar con nosotros
comenzamos hablando de que una encuesta
de routers de de routers ipsos publicada
el 14 de febrero encontró que tan solo
el 4% de los republicanos registrados
apoyan a Haley un porcentaje mínimo en
comparación al 43% que respalda Trump y
al 31% que respaldaría al gobernador de
Florida y posible precandidato ron de
santis cuál cree usted que es el
potencial con el que con el que hayley
puede conquistar a sus colegas de
partido
Ah muy buena pregunta y muchas gracias
María Clara Mira yo creo que
la liderazgo de
fue muy importante en el sur en su
momento pero cuando fue embajador Ya es
ex embajadora la embajadora ahora es
linda
pero cuando fue la embajadora no tuvo
mucha presencia en los medios durante
las épocas de lo único que pasó era una
pleito con Trump o con o no pero
realmente los movimientos en términos de
política dentro del mundo y no no había
una movimiento muy fuerte su candidatura
Se presenta como una persona de hasta de
la India de continente en la India y
ella fue una se presenta su candidatura
como una persona que no es ni negro ni
blanco y tiene una ventaja en términos
del sistema de racismo de Estados Unidos
pero en realidad el partido republicano
lo que ha hecho es levantar el racismo a
través de la forma que es la política de
Trump
Trump es el candidato Por lo cual existe
el el partido republicano Por lo cual no
hay una distinción entre segunda
candidatura porque no tiene relevancia
justamente los números se indica pero
tiene una ventaja que es que sea su
identidad y la identidad lo que está
tratando de lanzar adentro de de sus
campañas bueno la identidad Entonces
como una de las fortalezas que podría
promover hayley en su candidatura sin
embargo Aunque es la segunda
precandidato oficial de los republicanos
hay otros nombres en mente como el del
ex vicepresidente Mike pence quien
trabajó codo a codo con Trump sin
embargo desde la toma del Capitolio se
ha distanciado de Trump y ahora hace
parte por decirlo así de Lala más
moderada de los republicanos que tantas
opciones tendría pens teniendo en cuenta
estas divisiones dentro del partido
Pues no hay otra caridad más que que
Trump en el momento y el partido no
tiene forma y ni plan político para para
gestionar una nuevas políticas públicas
eso lo hemos visto en los primeros dos
semanas de enero con la falta de
conciliación por parte de los de la
cámara de de representantes donde Heaven
mccarthy estaba buscando seguimiento
para su candidatura no hay coordinación
no tienen voto popular no hay una como
red hilo de hilo para que gestiona una
política pública distinta Ellos dicen
que son de déficit cero y quieren cerrar
algunos quieren tener cláusuras de
cerrar
seguridad social lo cual son políticas
masivamente Popular en Estados Unidos
Entonces no hay una candidato no hay una
forma de política y no hay mayoría
Entonces veo muchos problemas en el
partido partido republicano en ese
momento para gestionar una una política
que no tiene que ver con un liderazgo
pura que es lo que es la política de
Joan Trump y quizás quién podría llegar
a cambiar esto es el gobernador de
Florida ron de santis quien se plantea
como un posible líder dentro del partido
en medio de estas divisiones de las que
usted nos habla Y es que siendo
gobernador de este estado ya ha
impulsado políticas bastante
republicanas en contra por ejemplo del
aborto o en contra de la diversidad
incluso de la niñez con la llamada
iniciativa no digas gay Usted cree que
la figura de ron de santis Sí podría
unificar a los republicanos de Cara a
las presidenciales o no es suficiente
no suficiente Yo creo que la política
del gobernador del de Virginia es mucho
más relevante porque él sí ha trabajado
en términos de El derecho de las madres
y los padres dentro de las escuelas este
centro de la decisión de las escuelas es
muy importante para los partidos y en
decisiones para tomar
acciones en las escuelas locales es más
importante que sí o no decir que o el
cuestión de aborto esos son no son
suficientes relevantes y no tiene
suficiente popularidad
fue una o sea por parte de la
presidencia que nombró los
Corte Suprema que ya ya la toma de
decisión por cambiar la política de
bordo fue por la mayoría en el Corte
Suprema Por lo cual es una
un tiroteo hacia una política externa
extremista que el voto popular no trae
Entonces veo muy lejos una política de a
una nueva o una política de haber en
Texas más masiva son demasiado polémicos
y no no tienen suficiente gestión atrás
para para gestionar una política pública
Pero hay ahí están buscando candidaturas
y posible política que que lanza
Entonces
Por lo cual por equivocación también
dijo en su video de lanzamiento que era
que no quería que los socialistas en
Estados Unidos no tenemos socialistas es
un país democrático liberal entonces
cada vez que escuchas que un político
habla de socialismo no existe en Estados
Unidos Entonces es una también un
tiriteo hacia una política distinta pero
lo cual no existe entonces hay
extremismo y racismo y aún están en
Estados Unidos entonces hay que vamos a
ver cómo resuelta en cuatro Pero veo muy
lejos una Independencia por una
candidatura por ejemplo
una política de
Sí y con esta entonces panorama que
usted nos da de las divisiones esto
haría que Donald Trump todavía siga
siendo el precandidato más fuerte de los
republicanos
totalmente
tiene suficiente
deber de organizar de jalar los votos de
los individuos que que tienen que tienen
Trump y Trump fue una o sea fue una
cuestión que nadie se esperaba y aún
siguen los Los
Paisanos en su favor Entonces es muy
difícil que una persona que era de
repente se va por otro candidato en el
partido republicano porque o sea es una
figura con demasiado poder individual
para que gestiona una una división
entonces literalmente esas noticias no
son noticias porque ya los analistas ya
tenían tenían la lista de potencias
candidaturas pero realmente Aquí no hay
no